ladies and gentlemen we have a very very
serious story I believe the Civil War
has begun what uh and yes it has started
and here's the story breaking news at
least one person injured as violence
breaks out between parents and lgbtq
supporters at La elementary school
that's right a pride flag was burned and
middle-aged women were swinging signs at
each other it is the Civil War that's it
that's how it starts that's how it
starts I've seen worse you know Black
Friday sales you know you know be really
crazy if the Civil War actually starts
with like a 52 year old you know
morbidly obese woman waving a you know
Pride sign and then some like
middle-aged mom being like get away from
my kids and then she like hits her with
a cardboard sign but she falls over and
like hits her head and gets seriously
injured and then people go nuts and then
100 years old like the Civil War started
when around the world yeah when the
American Civil War I was thinking like
it wasn't ideological it wasn't because
we talked about like what would cause
that abortion something like this trans
rights but it was economic all that war
was economic and they used the the war
to free the slaves like Lincoln was
idealistic but he used the economic War
so like
it it was you think that it would not
have happened if there was no slavery it
was ideological well it was it was that
the slave the South didn't want to pay
the north taxes anymore and so they're
like no you're going to be staying with
us and we're going to be collecting
that's not it was it's it's way more
complicated than that but when you had a
caning in Congress that is not about
economics that is tribal hatred and as a
division of cultures so it was an
ideological divide in this okay so
something sparked an economic divide I
see I see the economic divide is a
contributor to the tribal split but the
tribal split was very much rooted in a
plethora of issues and uh we've talked
about it a bit because I am no Civil War
historian but the initial states that
succeeded were later joined by I think
four other states who initially did not
secede and it was only after Lincoln uh
called for uh I think was conscription
to send people down to to quell the
Rebellion or whatever that several other
states were like okay we're voting for
secession and the interesting thing is
in these states it was not like it's not
like Virginia said we all 100 agree no
it was split in there in their uh in
their legislature it was mostly no we
don't want to do this then after the the
start of the conflict they said okay
we're going to re-vote and then they
leaned more so I think it was like two
to one or something and uh that's when
the Confederacy decided to make their
capital in Virginia because Virginia
wasn't one of the original states to
secede so anyway long story short it was
heavily ideological in that a large
Catalyst was Southern States believed
that Lincoln would would ban would
abolish slavery and it was a huge
component of their economies but very
many wealthy individuals uh profiting
from it whereas most people in southern
states did not own slaves and there was
like five percent or something really
small and then Lincoln was like no we're
just going to stop the expansion of it
into new States before he even got
elected before he was even inaugurated
they seceded I think he got elected then
they seceded then he gets inaugurated
then a few months later conflict breaks
out so anyway I don't want to use
there's a famous saying uh all wars or
Bankers Wars and and well Tim's
absolutely right that it was a very
complicated story with the the Civil War
this is why I oppose uh the sanctioned
regime that exists from the American
Empire it's always couched in this
concept of we're looking after the
downtrodden these these poor ukrainians
we have to now sanction and kick Russia
off of Swift and yada yada It ultimately
serves as a catalyst for more conflict
and More Death than it does deterring it
in my opinion I do want to go back and
say the the article in question we have
I was not intending to start a big civil
war debate my point was just more so
that parents have begun fighting with
lgbtq activists this is this is I think
lgbtq activists started fighting with
parents are fighting back well right so
so the fact that it's it's getting to
this level is showing that this will not
stand parents are saying it's a red line
for me about time yeah yeah it's
remarkable look at the signs stop
grooming our kids and it started during
covid that was and I I've said it before
I'll say it again that was this the
silver lining of covid was the zoom
classrooms and them being able to peer
into the classrooms and see what the
hell was actually going on in these
classrooms in the propaganda they were
pushing on these children you can't you
can't make a sign that has a word that
runs on to the next line though that's
that's what does it says stop utilizing
okay you can't you can't do it I mean I
agree with the sun together he's saying
but it could have been put together
better but I appreciate him being there
it's like a run-on sign it's it's a cult
man there is no Pride I'm happy though
because these are all great though it's
about time that the the like if parents
weren't willing to stand up for their
kids when they were being Force masked
but like finally this is a catalyst it's
just amazing to me like what it took to
get parents actually involved with this
stuff I'm calling it indoctrination
though I really
I I really don't like calling it
indoctrination we want indoctrination we
want teachers to wave American flags and
to show like here are the founding
fathers and the things they believed to
indoctrinate American values into these
children like literally indoctrinating
people into sexual perversion so they'll
do things that you consider sexual
sexually gratifying and trying to remove
them from parental supervision like
that's not indoctrination that's
grooming that is grooming that's why we
call it my butt so a lot of people say
like hey don't indoctrinate my kids like
no no no no no no don't indoctrinate
them with the weird Marxist stuff do
indoctrinate them with classical liberal
ideologies of the founding fathers
this is outside of Marxism and
patriotism right this is a totally
different category of degeneracy and
things that should not be I think it's
taught nicely with Marxism agree yeah
I just I feel like indoctrination is too
kind of a word for what's happening also
a grooming
what would you is the word too hot for
TV the word that you are considering
calling it probably
abuse I used to feel like man I don't
wanna I don't want to manipulate people
into worshiping the flag because this
country's responsible for so Much Death
and horror across earth of course a lot
of countries are exactly but now it's
not yeah now I'm more into like the
Constitution that I am into the flag
maybe the flag's supposed to like
identify our constitution I hope it does
what's your beef with the flag well
blind Allegiance I don't like that I
want to know what I'm swearing my
allegiance to Beyond just a color and a
picture and that's how I feel about a
lot of these presidential debates too it
just feels very um
it's tough because the government
doesn't really reflect the American
ethos anymore so like does that flag
still represent the American ethos I'm
not sure I like I still look at it
fondly but I can understand why someone
might look at it and go like well yeah
this is a hundred years of Empire and
control over the global frame like is
that something I want to pledge
allegiance to I don't know do you think
they haven't made a 51st state because
they're like these weird cultists these
weird like occult dudes that are like 50
is such a round number let's stay here
forever I agree with that I feel like 51
would be weird
we'll start a new staple we'll just lump
it in with a pre-existing thing I mean
like this is the territory of Idaho we
have a 50. Puerto Rico like part of
Idaho
we give them more welfare than any other
state come on yeah I mean I would rather
we took was 150 billion or whatever
literally really just give it to Puerto
Rico uh Puerto Rico needs to help man
yeah
we need to take away the government's
credit card we're going to economically
develop this part of our own country
like we have parts of our dude I would
rather they gave 100 million dollars to
a random veteran I would rather
people I'm sorry is it billion it's
billion right 150 billion yes they
should literally just be like
if I if I Republican in Congress should
say
from now like I'm gonna enter the bill
that says all new funding for Ukraine
will instead be placed into a random
lottery for a veteran
yeah
one day you get a phone call and they're
alive we know you're better than their
research on Golf and space you just won
100 billion dollars really the money was
going to go to Ukraine but this new bill
went through and the money's yours and
they're gonna go oh okay tax refund yeah
I think Ted give it back to the people
who wanted it well give that money back
they can't give it back that's all or
pay off the debt I'll print it and
borrowed money so right yeah get just
get rid of it pay off the debt whatever
it is think about what they could do
with 150 billion dollars they could make
they could build a spaceship you know
they could build a lot of spaceships
with that they could well the private
sector could the Democrat I mean like
the Democrats
I'm saying they they pay a private
company they could uh they could have
bought Twitter three times over that's
right they could they could have bought
a bunch of twitters and isn't it funny
that when Elon Musk bought Twitter it
was how many poor people could he have
fed with this like okay every time the
government throws far more absurd sums
of money at nonsense we never hear this
that could have fed the poor argument
ever the the closest they'll come to it
is we could have spent this on social
welfare programs while ignoring that
like our social welfare spending
actually outpaces our military budget
people don't realize this the amount we
spend on welfare uh Medicare Medicaid
um all of the the different meddling and
the the health care industry and Social
Security it's insane it's insane we we
spend so much so much money
and we're 31 trillion dollars in debt
and they're like well I don't like how
Elon spent that money you're concerned
about how Elon is spending his money are
you serious what about the way the
government is spending your money is the
only one trying to save Humanity I'm
gonna say something controversial but I
think it is true we would as a country
be better off with the 150 billion
dollars going to Hunter Biden if he
couldn't spend it on Ukraine instead of
Ukraine because at the very least he'd
be spending it in the United States or
like if that was it like the crack trade
would flourish it would have erupt I
mean but but like what I'm saying is
think of the worst person in this
country the worst person you know and
just save some money to him and not the
government we're going to give you 100
billion dollars it has to be spent in
the United States and you can't do
anything illegal we would be better off
than giving it to Ukraine but the thing
that's good about the UK manufacturing
war war what is it good for yeah
the Ukraine thing that's good for the
bankers is that we loaned 150 billion to
Ukraine so Ukraine is going to have to
borrow 150 billion from the bank of
international settlements to pay it back
to us then the bank for international
settlements gets to collect interest on
300 billion because I think it's IMF but
it's discovered that it's one big circle
jerk and then when when the war is over
when whatever happens Ukraine will
forever be paying debt or what they'll
do is they'll say instead of paying the
debt we're just going to take your land
we're going to own it now belong to
Blackrock or our subsidiary as well the
future for Ukraine is very very Bleak
and that's assuming we avoid any sort of
nuclear exchange thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time